well this this little packet that we're
in don't you love this is this the first
this is the first time yeah well i love
this blue
blue velvet the purse that we're in you
know it's like a sex panic room
with microphones have you ever been in a
sex panic yeah what's a sex i have yeah
i have been in a sex panic myself
see that's the problem that's why i envy
you is is
this
i don't think jeff would ever be in a
sex panic jeff cook
even when there's nothing sexual
happening i'm in a sex panic i'm
constantly in my own head he's the
antidote because he could be a sex calm
like a sex bomb to your sex panic
this is
who did that song sex bomb it wasn't
bomb but it was bomb oh yeah was that uh
b-52s no it was a big hit in europe
particularly during these couple years
that i remember sex boxes
you only remember a couple of years we
got it no during these couple when it
was a hit
he's looking it up when it was a hit i
was in europe making a movie and it was
on all the time but i don't think it
made its way across the pond
and there was a video i'll give you a
clue that same
singer
is not unusual oh tom jones yeah
exactly what james bond thunderball
oh yeah
[Music]
that johnny cash did a rejected
thunderball theme song i did not know
that
he did unsolicited sent it to them and
they went we never asked for this it was
not that song it was his own song you
know can i say something yeah and this
is to be because i know a lot about
johnny cashier if you're him yeah he
sent in a lot of unsolicited songs he
was constantly uh sending in like prell
shampoo alpo dog food he was constantly
yeah he's constantly sending in i've got
a different way you could go with that
song um uh purina cat chow
yeah he first sang that song look sharp
feel sharp
be sharp
all right
bring them down down or burn apart
stuck
oh and you know what uh i mean
no no wasn't the one
you know what the sad last thing he did
before he passed away was the car for
kids jingle oh yeah i don't know that
jingle bell sing it
1-800 cars for kids something like that
okay no but i think the oscar may i
think would you i'd like to be an oscar
meyer wiener oh i'd like to be an oscar
my wiener i want her out of nothing
yeah i would like to be asking my wiener
that is what i really like to be like
now all the kids would be in love with
me yes ah fell into a burning ring of
fire
just so you know to be fair that most
jingles that you love were written by
johnny cash that's true unsolicited he
would just send him in yeah
but he did do the thunderball this is
how we got started
dropping mental breadcrumbs he did send
in the thing what did you say and it
sounds like a typical johnny cash song
except it has kind of like john berry
horns in it it's really something i love
that i love that thunderbolt i was right
at the right age for that because i had
consumed dr no from russia with love
goldfinger i was so ready for
thunderball
that was great he is he your favorite
bond of all time ah
i'm going to say for me it's sean
connery
but daniel craig
is right there with him and i thought no
one could do that i thought no one could
sean connery was so incredible fantastic
when he peaked when he went to the
summit of the alps after thunderball i
think nothing against john connery those
movies yeah it started to he was phoning
it in wither yeah and by the time he got
to jill st john and diamonds are forever
forever
you know i'm not my favorite uh
i've never been happier in my life right
i know you're you this is
your family this is i'll tell you matt
gurley is a bond fanatic and a huge jeff
goldblum fan now he's in a room they've
both come together and he's having a
nocturnal emission oh my god there's so
many emissions i diurnal emission all
day long here this is
what yeah the what the what diurnal
diurnal the oh is that the daytime the
diurnal i believe so diurnal diurnal
diurnal diarrheal neural diurnal i
believe i know that song johnny cash
first said okay listen
he submitted all my
bar mitzvah
you know what makes perfect it fell into
a burning ring it's becoming more elvis
it's becoming more elvish
i never said i was the perfect